Hi, this is Dr. Kevin Connors, and this is a very, very short video.
Just introducing you to our nutritional consultations with one of our nutritionists.
We decided to add this feature to our clinic because we have numerous people that are just
looking for that small piece of the puzzle of their healthcare.
What to do from a nutritional standpoint, dietary supplementary, and they just need to talk
to a professional about that.
So that's what this page is all about.
We created just a simple two-step procedure for you to follow.
Call our office and schedule a free consultation.
There's no charge for it.
It's only going to be about 15 to 30 minutes, and we're not going to overview your entire
health history, but it does give us an idea to give you a direction, and it gives you some
confidence in moving forward.
And the number two step two is to complete our online forum.
You'll see below this video, and that will always be your confidentiality.
We'll be protected.
We'll receive that form, and then we'll get started with the call.
These are all done over the phone.
One of our nutritionists will call you and go over any major concerns that you have, and
give you some direction.
So we hope this is a blessing to a lot of people.
Thanks.